Mark Zuckerberg is in the fight of his
life
better the parent company of Facebook
Instagram and WhatsApp has lost three
quarters of its market value since
September 2021. it's facing a bunch of
issues the economy is hurting the
advertising Market where it makes 98 of
its money apple is meanwhile making it
harder to make money from mobile
advertising and Tick Tock is hoovering
up the young users that advertisers so
love the pivot to the metaverse as the
company likes to call augmented and
virtual reality was supposed to be the
solution to zuck's problems but so far
it's only accentuating them investors
aren't happy at the tens of billions of
dollars that the company is spending on
unproven Tech the challenge is Apple
which may have a significant advantage
over Zuck and Co to make any hardware
platform appealing you need to have lots
of amazing apps take the iPhone whose
sales only went stratospheric after 2011
when the App Store was introduced and to
have amazing apps you need to have lots
of developers Apple has by its own
Reckoning more than 30 million
registered developers and it's been
given giving them the tools and
encouraging them to build augmented
reality apps since 2017. that's laid the
groundwork for any AR device it might
ultimately release there's a counter
Narrative of course Apple might show why
the metaverse is awesome and meta will
benefit from that but the key thing is
that investors just don't know for sure
and that uncertainty means they're
punishing the share price